[Music]
we're checking out one plusses concept
phone this is actually the first time
that they're showing it CES and this is
inspired by the McLaren 720s what's
really special about this is this glass
is electrochromic glass so what that
means is much like the McLaren or in
some of the Boeing planes where you
press a button and the glass goes from
transparent to dark this also does that
so you guys can't see it right now but
the camera is inside of here
I'll give you a quick little demo let me
open up the camera app did you see hit
[Applause]
[Music]
oneplus is attention to details always
something that I love again inspired by
the McLaren this is all leather it is
stitched and they even have a 24 karat
gold-plated edge all the way around
another thing that I love is obviously I
shoot a lot with my phone outside so
this will also act as an ND filter and
that's something that I've never seen on
a cell phone ever so if you're outside
shooting this will activate and you'll
be able to get really great outdoor
photos especially when it's really
bright out it also activates very
quickly it takes point seven seconds to
activate and this glass is 0.35
millimeters thin like I can see you but
can you see me yeah okay
you're very close okay so should I move
back since this is a concept we have no
idea what this price is when it'll be
released but this is definitely
something that I'm excited to see what
oneplus ends up doing with this they're
always thinking about the future and I
can't wait to see what they end up with
[Music]